yes i wrote a study which was why and
how capitalism needs to be reformed
which was a very controversial study but
but it's an obvious fact that if it's
not benefiting the majority of the
people
okay then just by its metrics of success
it's not a it's not going to be
successful but these types of changes
some have to be reformed because the
country or the world as a whole has more
resources than it ever had it has more
intelligence than it ever had but he has
a choice is it going to go to war
or is it and which will make things
worse than ever or is it going to try to
find a way in together to make that
better whole that's the choice i think
we face
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to the podcast one of the
greatest investors of all time that's no
exaggeration to say
and number one new york times
best-selling author including author of
the extraordinary new book principles
for dealing with a changing world order
why nations succeed and fail
ray dalio the head of bridgewater the
biggest hedge fund in the world joins us
thank you so much for being here ray
thank you for the opportunity to talk
with you and your audience you kidding
ray i mean i've admired you for a long
time and my my first question for you is
why the heck are you doing this which
what i mean by a lot by this is like
you're putting your thoughts and ideas
out there uh you know a lot of people
like in your line of work um i suppose
and even in your book you say it's like
hey some of the things i'm putting out
there some people are you know are going
to be reactive to
and you talk about how polarized our
climate is like why is it so important
for you to get these ideas out there
well i'm at a stage in my life you know
i'm 72 years old and the most important
thing i could do is pass along whatever
i have that's of value so
you know the main thing i feel a natural
pull to is passing along some of the
principles that helped me and
and then talking about these issues and
then i'm going to then go
quiet probably after i put out my next
book which is economic investment
principles if we don't talk about these
things these very important things
i worry
um because there are things that are
dangerous that are going on that we can
have an influence on so i worry so what
should i do just be quiet and to be to
myself i think this is a moment to talk
about them so that's why i also
appreciate um you and and
being able to have this conversation
well really
grateful for your incredible uh work
with this book which i really want
everyone to read i think it helps shed
light on a lot of the forces that that
people feel like
are buffeting americans and number one
right now on top of everyone's mind is
inflation and the book kind of predates
this sort of inflation surge
um but you talk about how there's this
mega there are three mega cycles you
talk about in the book there's like the
money credit cycle uh where the money
supply goes up
and inflation becomes a growing problem
and then there's this internal order
disorder uh cycle which we'll talk about
a little bit and then the external order
disorder cycle now that we're in this
particular bind like what do you foresee
for
uh the fed right now in terms of trying
to address inflation and get it under
control you write admiringly about paul
volcker in the 70s that you actually
were friendly with him or worked with
him um i feel like
the fed today has a tougher task ahead
of them than even faced volcker in the
70s is that fair to say
yeah let me let me put it in context um
one of the things that i learned in my
life
is that
things that surprised me often never
happened in my lifetime before
and that i needed to study them going
back in in 1971 on august 15th when i'm
clerking on the floor of the new york
stock exchange and following these
things between in the year between
graduating college and
uh going to graduate school richard
nixon
defaults on the united states as stat
then then gold was money and i was
shocked i thought a crisis wow you're
not going to get the gold money as we
know it ends and i walked on to the
floor of the stock exchange and rather
than falling a lot which i thought would
happen it went up a lot and that's
because i never was through one of those
one of those devaluations and so on and
so i started studying in history and i
found out the same thing happened
on march 3rd 1933
roosevelt did the exact same thing for
the exact same reason leading to the
exact same result
and so studying past periods
that didn't happen in my lifetime like
we haven't been through a war before and
we haven't been through a civil war or
we haven't been in the circumstances so
the three big things that are happening
in our lifetimes that we have not been
through before
are
the creation of an enormous amount of
debt and printing of money to monetize
the debt that's number one
and so we'll talk about inflation and
where we are in that cycle but i and i'm
i'm like a mechanic i'm not ideological
i'm just like what are the cause effect
relationships how does that dynamic work
mechanistically but it produces uh
inflation uh the second but very
interrelated to this
is the large internal conflicts that we
are having populism of the left and
populism of the right um
and values differences that is producing
a conflict populism means that some
representative who will fight for me on
my cause
against the other side that means not
not compromise not be in the middle but
to fight to win at all costs and when we
have that populism brought about also by
the largest wealth gap differences
largest opportunity gap differences and
so on that type of conflict i have never
seen in my life but that also happened
in the 19
period and so i needed to go back and
and study that over time and then the
third is
the great power conflict right when 1945
when this world order began
um as all world orders there's a war
there's a dominant power the dominant
power sets the rules and when the
dominant power sets the rules uh then
you have a period of peace and
prosperity um and so
the united states in 1945 had 80 percent
of the world's money it had half of
world gdp it had a monopoly on the
military power and so we came into the
american world order
that gap that power gap has shrunk to be
approximately equal with the other side
and we're having a great power conflict
so you have to go back to that period of
time and i've seen that period of time
happen
repeatedly when these three things
happen repeatedly it's a very dangerous
set of circumstances so we are in a
position on the financial one to be in a
position where you you cannot raise
living standards by raising money and
credit in other words if you increase
money then the value of money is going
to go down
and one man's debts are another man's
assets
and so
uh when they get negative returns by
holding a debt asset they're going to
sell that debt asset and that produces a
a problem and that hap that's over a
period of time and so the romans for
example put um less gold into gold coins
and so you saw it in its way and that
certainly produces kind of the inflation
because you can't raise living standards
by printing more money
so we have that going on that was really
the essence of your first question and
so there's that dynamic of uh where is
the storehold of wealth the purpose of a
currency is two purposes a medium of
exchange and a storeholder of wealth a
storehold of wealth means you you buy it
its data and its assets and you can save
in it and people believe that cash is a
safe investment but they're seeing that
what happens is it's losing buying power
and it will lose buying power so they
start to realize it's not a safe
investment inflation of last year about
eight percent interest rates were
were nothing and so there was an eight
percent change in buying power that kind
of changes and sort of reinforces the
inflation cycle so one of the
fascinating arguments you make in your
book
is you go through the various
alternatives to the dollar as the world
reserve currency so here's the the way
most people understand it the u.s is
printing a lot of money
because it's running significant
deficits it owes now um 30 trillion plus
or something along those lines um but
the world doesn't have much of a choice
because where else you're gonna put
your investment or savings the eurozone
too small
uh the deutsche mark the pound
the pound probably doesn't even exist
anymore it's an ugly contest
yeah yeah it's like so so the u.s looks
at it and it's like hey like what are
you gonna do you know it's like that
it's the us dollar or nothing um and you
make an argument that that's not quite
how it works right that i think
we pay too much attention
to one currency in relationship to
another currency and not enough
attention to the fact that those aren't
the choices it's a choice for
transactions but it's not a choice for
storehold of wealth so if you're holding
european euros and euro denominated debt
and you're getting a negative interest
rate or thereabouts and the same is true
in japan and you're not making up with
inflation none of those are good
it's a
and like in the 30s they all depreciated
they all went down in relationship to
goods and services
and other asset prices so what you see
is all the currencies uh along those
lines
are sort of tied to each other and
they're bad storeholds of wealth and
that's why you see moves to other assets
it pays to borrow and uh or if not
borrowed but put your money into
um assets that maintain buying power so
you see it happen in all the different
ways so
look at whether what you're holding in
the form of that
uh cash
denominated and that'll be a debt
instrument that's how you hold the
currency to in order to have a storehold
of wealth look at its real returns yeah
and you use gold in your book uh as a
standard of reference which is something
that most people are familiar with
one question that i that did pop into my
mind when i was reading your book was
whether the phenomena you're describing
um are
tied to the rise of crypto over like the
this last period of time because it it
seems like people have been casting
about for in some ways alternative to
fiat currencies that aren't gold
uh is is that something that uh that you
think is an outgrowth of what you're
describing
it has the form together
of what is money
i mean it's genesis what is money and
how can we
not only digitalize it which makes it
some extent efficient
but also
the real questions
can it maintain
value so it will
not be depreciated by central banks
that's a that's that's a key thing
can it be
transferred used all around the world
accepted for
purchases and sales all around the world
then it has to do with issues like can
it be
private
there's a saying in gold's case which is
it's the only
financial asset that you can own
that is private and you can move around
that
isn't dependent on somebody paying you
money
paying you something
so as a medium of exchange so uh crypto
those in a fiat world uh naturally
becomes a alternative uh consideration
and the fact that it's gone on
uh something like bitcoin i guess about
11 years and and it hasn't been hacked
and you know it's working in that way
has its particular appeal it has big
issues it's not a it's not a private
asset uh it is
um easily outlawed it it doesn't
constitute a high enough percentage of
wealth it's um like right now for
example bitcoins worth maybe
700 billion dollars or so and which
makes it a small asset by comparison to
a lot of things like microsoft is worth
more than um crypto is and so it's not
it hasn't reached those particular
stages i think that
people are
grappling for what the new money will be
in this environment
and i think
we don't know yet what the new money is
i think we're going to see different
countries
put out their different versions of
digital countries currencies and then
there will be private assets and and
gold will play a role the important
thing is we have entered an era
um which will carry us through the next
number of years
of
what is the money
that is widely accepted
as a medium of exchange and
a viable storehold of wealth
if you've been keeping up with me at all
you know that i am very concerned about
the fact that every time we surf the web
on our phone or computer our data is
getting spirited away
by big companies that will just sell our
data to the highest bidder that's not a
good time i'd rather that we are
protected and anonymous online which is
why i use expressvpn what's expressvpn
vpn stands for virtual private network
express you can figure that part out
what it does is it allows you to surf do
your thing and no one is the wiser it's
like incognito mode that actually works
i know incognito mode doesn't do what it
says it's gonna do anyway
when your phone carrier tracks you
that's a gross invasion of your privacy
you can either keep letting them cash in
on you or you can visit expressvpn.com
yang to get the same vpn i use take back
your online privacy today and use my
link to get three extra months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang expressvpn.com
yang protect your data
[Music]
so as the mechanic and you've studied
these patterns over and over again for
me the biggest
analog to what we're going through right
now is the 70s and obviously you know no
one has a crystal ball though to the
extent that anyone has a crystal ball i
suspect yours is better than
most anyone's
but like how do you see
this inflation
interest rate
asset price tension playing out i feel
like the fed's gonna have no choice but
to increase interest rates and i'm not
sure what happens next the fed
understands and not central banks know
that when
uh inflation
is undesirably high uh undesirably high
and economy is relatively strong you put
on the brakes
and that when the reverse is the case
you put on the gas
and they don't understand i think
monetary inflation enough
what has happened is that because
they put on the gas
so much have allowed
interest rates
to be so low as i say in many cases
negative
interest rates
and they've made liquidity so abundant
that not only didn't you have to pay
interest on your debt
but you didn't have to pay principal on
your debt because they would have
interest only loans
and they would have um low
covenants like it's easy to
not meet your debt requirement companies
borrow individuals borrow interest only
loans and when there's no interest rate
meaning basically mean the stuff is free
you can buy houses you can buy all sorts
of things on that basis and the world
has adapted to that and they did that at
a very low
real interest rate a very low
interest rate relative to inflation and
then they printed a lot more of that
money and so on and so inflation is
going up
so mechanistically
what that means is now we have a lot
more
debt
and we have an economy and a markets
financial markets that the pricing is
structured based on those very low
interest rates and that amount of
liquidity so when you go through the
calculations when i go through the
calculations
and i
i figure um a high enough level of
interest rate
to provide a decent real return
is for a holder of the debt
is much too high of an interest rate for
the markets in the economy but you're
going to have an inflation rate that's
above the interest rates
and
and that's not going to be desirable so
investors want to sell that
and you could see it as interest rates
rise
you can see its effects on markets you
could see the effects on the capital
markets
so you see the stock market going down
while the bond market is going down and
that means most everything that people
own practically are going down
practically um because most people are
in stocks and bonds that kind of thing
the fed's trade-off
is going to be very difficult
right now they have a very restrictive
monetary policy plan
i judge that by the supply and the
demand
for credit
so the federal government is going to
run large deficits so that means they
will have to sell debt
they'll sell treasury bills and bonds
the federal reserve is planning to sell
1.1 trillion dollars of debt also
private investors
are inclined pension funds and so on
they're losing money
while there's inflation so they're
losing buying power they're selling
and there's a selling imbalance
and that selling imbalance
means because it has to balance with the
buyers that means a contraction in
private credit which means a recession
so as i look through this
we're in a tightening phase where it's
beginning to bite but it's not
really it's barely begun because the
actual rises in short rates have barely
begun
it started the other things are rising
and that trade-off between growth and
inflation is going to be very difficult
and that's why i believe that we've
entered a period of in of stagflation
quite like the
1970s and then we can't look at it alone
we have to look at it in light of the
two other big forces in other words the
internal conflict force we don't have
enough money and we don't have enough
real money we have plenty of fiat money
because we can print it but you don't
have enough real money and everybody
says we need to um spend money on this
thing and that and i and i don't even
disagree with that when i look at the
social conditions and the infrastructure
and i look at okay on ukraine and do we
need to be rebuild the ukraine do we
need to have greater military
expenditures do we need to have these
things but we don't ask how much money
do we have to spend
and so because of the nature of that
even just the costliness we need to take
care of the environment
but it's going to be expensive when we
take care of the environment because
we haven't yet fully developed the
technologies that are fully cost
effective in order to do that so i think
that that's the mechanical description
of of where we are in a political
environment so as we have inflation
um that's going to be a big political
thing
and it's going to cause greater polarity
there's a risk that neither side accepts
losing
because of the populism and you put more
financial strain and things get worse
conditions are likely to be
significantly worse for example in 2024
than they are now just take a normal
economic cycle and where you are
and then we have the external conflict
thing yeah they're all tied together and
it paints a difficult picture i think
the most important thing
is how we are with each other through
these types of things whether we're
fighting with each other or you know the
smart middle
where you know you work together and you
bring the country together not to fight
because history has shown
we have to bring up make our country
strong
[Music]
you had a sentence in your book that i
thought was maybe the strongest sentence
i'd ever seen from a business leader
that uh i was not aware of until i read
your book in full which was you said
that you think that the odds of america
slipping into a civil war type
scenario
over the next 10 years is around 30
percent and you characterize that as
like not that high a risk i feel like
that should be
a1
headline news
everywhere and by the way i'm with you
like i i agree with you here's what i
think
is happening
and and probably will happen
the populism of the left and the right
uh are individuals who will
are fighters
for those constituencies
and
there are very different values very
different approaches what that means is
that there's little compromise and
there's much greater extremism very much
like happened in europe four major
democracies in the
1930-45 period had this type of internal
conflict that ended up their parliaments
their uh legislatures choosing to have
autocracies that they went to
autocracies on germany italy japan and
spain and if you study history you see
it was the same in the fresh revolution
the russian revolution the cuban
revolution the chinese revolution which
are all sort of civil wars you lose the
middle and because you have to say
andrew you got to get on one side or
another and fight when the causes that
people are behind
are more important to them than the
system the system is in jeopardy and so
you see just even uh people moving from
place to place in terms of where they
think
it's more uh sympathetic to their way of
being and what they're like you know new
york chicago uh san francisco california
moves to texas and so on and you're
seeing um then
um not a not as much respect for
the constitution and the legal system
because you have a win at all cost so
for example if you have the dispute
between um let's say disney and um the
florida governor in the past there would
have been almost mutual respect for
different points of view but what you
now get back is you get back to a power
conflict well you know what would the
odds put i'll ask you what you think the
odds are uh that for example in the next
presidential election that neither side
accepts losing you know i'd say
almost too close to call
um
and what is the possibility that states
do not follow the directions of the
supreme court decisions because the
supreme court decisions can be viewed by
one side as a political decision made by
the other supreme court and how do we
get around that or whatever just like
sanctuary cities in other words i will
not follow that rule
and that and so now you start to have a
breakdown of
the system and you have power politics
determining things so i think that that
kind of uh civil war is
relatively likely i i don't disagree
with you at all ray anyone who listens
to me knows that i've been trying to
sound an alarm on this so one of the
things you say in your book is that you
think one way out of this is a strong
peacemaker and we pray for them
uh but you say that that's not something
that uh generally happens that generally
the other thing happens
um what what i'm trying to do have you
seen any of uh catherine gell or
michael's or michael porter's work on
political incentives because well one of
the things that's driving our
polarization is that we have these party
primaries that disproportionately
empower the most extreme 10 percent of
partisan voters so one thing we're
trying to do is change the mechanics of
the our elections so that it's not just
the most extreme
uh hyper partisans choosing our leaders
and then reelecting them right now you
have
20 of americans happy with congress
which is very very low
but the re-election rate for individual
members is 94 which is astronomically
high but your book talks about the
increase in polarization as a precursor
to some of these very negative things
happening and there are other societies
that have democracies that have more
than two parties
that's actually the norm in most of the
world and so what we're trying to do it
forward is change the mechanics that you
can have more points of view emerge and
then start a positive unifying
third-party force that represents the
reasonable middle
that can draw energy and resources and
also put pressure on both of the parties
to compromise
i don't know if this is something that
you've dug into and explored either in
terms of the mechanics of why
it seems like we're getting
more extreme polarized leadership um or
if there have been other countries that
have uh reformed their way out so i i i
think we're uh completely in agreement
let's and just going back to the
mechanics i i think it has to do
with fear i hope
that we can have understand what the
context what what it means to have the
type of civil war the what is the
probability and what does that mean
um like i have a principle if you worry
you don't have to worry and if you don't
worry you need to worry
that's a pretty good rule of life
if you worry
you'll take care of the thing you're
worrying about and you can worry less
and and
if you don't then probably it'll kill
you the extremism
which um has problems in terms of
destroying a system is a terrible path
anybody who's gone through this and i i
mean it
domestically as well as internationally
but the number one thing
is that the population has got to want
that and we have and in our two-party
system we have a problem because um
let's say there's about 30 percent of
the population i i would define
as being uh rather
extreme right
and maybe something like 15 percent of
the population being extreme left but as
a percentage of their
uh
own parties they're relatively high
and they're gathering more as their as
the fight approaches
and so they become then dominant and you
have that particular result
but the power of the middle
if you can and and the power of of of
also compromise if you can bring that
about i is enormous because still
the majority of people are not in those
two we're we're talking about 45 of the
population maybe is is fairly extreme
and opposite ends
um but the majority still aren't there
and if the majority
had they have to be smart enough
to know how to increase the size of the
pie and divide the pie well to create
produce equal opportunity and equal and
some element of sharing it to get the
balance right you wrote a number of
pieces in 2018 and 2019 about how we
need to try and reform the economy or
reform capitalism capitalism so that it
works for more people and one of the
stats that you cited was a stat that i
cited too on the trail which was that
the odds of american children doing
better than their parents
are down to let's say 50 50 and dropping
which is one of the things that's
driving people to anger frustration i
mean it's very fundamental you're a
parent i'm a parent if you felt like
your kids are gonna do worse than you
then you start looking around being like
okay what the heck is is going wrong yes
i wrote a study which was why and how
capitalism needs to be reformed which
was a very controversial study but but
it's an obvious fact
that if it's not benefiting the majority
of the people
okay then just by its metrics of success
it's not a it's not going to be
successful yeah and there are and
reformed doesn't mean
gone away with it means changing certain
things
that means it works better keeping
capitalism and so on capitalists tend to
be people who um have new ideas and if
you give them capital and they can
invent really good things and improve it
it you know it's a wonderful system it's
been proven by everybody it's been
adopted by the chinese dang you ping to
make a better uh system but it has to
work in a way where it produces the
outcomes that you want the middle
the problem is capitalists are better
able of increasing the pie but they
don't know how to divide the pie well
they don't have to share it well and
socialists don't know how to make it as
good a pie but they divide it well so i
think you need the bipartisan like if i
was president of the united states which
by the way i will never be i'm not
running but i would want to have a
bipartisan cabinet
okay i'd put a bipartisan cabinet
and i would have the equivalent to a
manhattan project to think about what
reforms need to be made to achieve that
uh in other words of the left of the
right smart capable mechanical
least savvy individuals who know about
engineering and there will have to be
structural changes for example let's say
education
uh the constitution uh makes um
education a stated
issue which then is in most states
become the local tax district issue i
know this well because my wife um
and i to some except her really works in
the worst
school districts in connecticut i'll
give you a stock shocking statistic in
connecticut which is one of the richest
states in the country
22 percent of the high school students
are either disengaged or disconnected
disengaged means that their absentee
rate is greater than 25 percent they're
failing class oh my gosh and
disconnected means that they don't know
where they are because they dropped out
of school 22 of the high school students
are failing
high school now there's a cycle there
they're in a poorest district they're
not they don't have parents to
adequately take care of them and so on
the state of connecticut spends 600
billion dollars a million dollars a year
on incarcerations
because there's that so the notion like
there's no better investment than
quality education
but these types of changes some have to
be reformed maybe it requires some
constitutional amendments but it
certainly means working together because
the country or the world as a whole has
more resources than it ever had it has
more intelligence than it ever had but
it has a choice is it going to go to war
or is it and which will make things
worse than ever or is it going to try to
find a way
together to make that better whole
that's the choice i think we face
[Music]
i urge anyone to read rey's piece on how
to
reform and restore capitalism because i
agree with it
entirely if productivity
is to work it has to benefit the
population broadly and do we have that
right now when you ask that sort of
rhetorically but it's clear everyone
knows we don't you know that like
productivity's hitting certain people
and like not benefiting others yeah i uh
the reason i use measurements
is i want to be totally objective
and i want to be totally mechanical if
this move this lever this works this way
and so you could see it in those pieces
in the books um by the way i'd um
besides my book i did a um
about a 40 minute video uh animated
video uh called the changing world order
i put it out a little over a month ago
and it's got 13 million viewers people
like it it's a quick and easy way oh
we'll link to it for sure uh we we know
a lot of people uh prefer to get their
information that way we got to give it
to them in every way possible
book
podcast animated video just to
try and
lead people to it um so ray you wrote
that piece about reforming capitalism in
uh 2018 or 2019 is that right yeah i
think it was 18 but maybe 19. yeah i
think it was 18 as well i remember being
struck by it i was just starting my
presidential run i was like wow and you
said we should declare a national
emergency slash manhattan project around
why the economy is not working for most
people
and the reason i the reason i wrote it
was at 2016
for the first time we had a populist
being elected
populist of the right and i studied
populism and then i decided i would
study it
like let me diagnose what's going on and
i did it by my quintiles top 20 next 20
percent and i wanted to look what the
circumstances were for the majority of
people so the bottom 60 percent
and and when i saw that
i got it
i mean
it was clear
okay it's not working for the majority
of of people yeah and you say too that
our socioeconomic mobility has dropped
like a stone where you imagine that this
is a country where you can move between
quintiles and it really hasn't been true
for a while and it's an engineer i view
it as an engineering problem right
so because profitability
has a cycle
that doesn't
um necessarily
achieve the goal
fully
it's wonderful things about it but at
the same time
capitalism as it creates big differences
those
those reinforce each other so um if you
have a lot of money
your kids get a good education
if you don't and you're poor in poverty
they don't get a good education
or you have more power or those things
and also ironically
you get more indebted the country
becomes more indebted
and and if you look at the assets and
liabilities if you're richer you can
borrow money
and that's why i like to support
microfinance but anyway if you're richer
you can borrow money
and you own stocks and bonds and when
the federal reserve
buy stocks and bonds for monetary policy
purposes you get more rich relative to
others and so there are engineering
reasons
that are
um that exist and if they were modified
um it would improve incentives it would
improve productivity people think it's
just a wealth transfer no no it's a
productivity trend
yes it's actually just trying to improve
the engineering so my question for you
is this and this is where where i think
we are right but so you you raise your
hand and in my opinion very
iconic classically say hey look the
american economy is not working for the
bottom 60 percent this is going to lead
to very negative things based upon like
history and cycles and everyone ever
what every other society has gone
through when they've been in this
position we need to move in this
direction imagine a bipartisan
government and cabinet coming together
to implement these things
um the the problem i see is that right
now if either party is in power their
incentives are not to work with the
other side because of just the way the
system is set up again if you compromise
with the other side then you'll likely
pay a price at the polls and your job
security will go down so the
the vision you have is a vision i share
very deeply
and we need to try and get the country
there as quickly as we can
my feeling is that the only way to get
there is going to be to try and uh
reform or
frankly disrupt the current two-party
system there are a couple of ways to do
that and i'm going to throw something
out there i sense that you're friendly
with mark cuban so i i've been uh
bugging mark to run for president in in
24 uh he's been demurring just like you
did you know 15 minutes ago
but that
if there was like a mark cuban type
figure that runs for office like i think
he wins um because if you wind up with
like a trump biden rematch 58 of
americans want an alternative to that um
so they'll just look around saying like
is there an alternative and then if you
had like a credible
independent figure then uh you could
imagine a cuban type get there and then
he'd appoint a bipartisan cabinet and
then there there'd be a chance to
accomplish what you laid out i guess i
have two questions number one what was
the result you saw from your making that
case like and i know you've been
investing through your personal
philanthropy in uh you know in
connecticut um you know with with your
wife in various ways um and the second
thing is i have made the diagnosis that
our current two-party system is actually
becoming less and less prone to
some form of uh compromising
collaboration like you prescribe like i
believe our only way to get there would
be some kind of political realignment
reorientation you know i've started a
third party to try and help us get there
we're like building state chapters and
the rest of it um like what do you see
as like
like a path to the vision that you laid
out
uh in 2018
uh so first of all i i completely agree
with you um meaning
that there has to be a political
alignment of
people who are in the middle who
and they are
um i see it
um that republicans and democrats are
more alike
than
they are with the
members of the party who are more
extreme
yeah great
and so the question is whether it should
be a third political party
um or it should be a
bringing together those moderates in
some other form
um that has them working together
within their existing parties but
working together closely
and i don't know the relative pros and
cons of that
it would seem off the top of my view as
very
as it might be difficult
to have somebody says i'm stepping away
as being a democrat or a republican and
i'm entering the party of the middle
but on the other hand once they've made
that choice
um that helps to create a cohesiveness
and a coordination that makes that go
better i know that in a presidential
election
it's a very long shot because of the
nature of the political um system i
spoke with mike bloomberg about this
because
um
you know he would have been a logical
candidate but i don't think it's very
difficult and i think it would be very
powerful
at other levels because it doesn't as
long as we abide by the rules
it doesn't take many
to determine how things go
because each of the other sides i mean
like right now it's one or two senators
um determines you know how things go
well you have a a a middle
that constitutes a stronger middle
and as long as the rule of law and the
constitution is followed it can make the
tipping point and it could be the most
powerful party even without having
you know the
in many ways the largest number of
people or the biggest budget and so on
so it seems uh conceivable but i'm not
an expert on that at that level i'm just
an agreeing
agreeing
that uh we need something like that
yeah we we need to get to what you're
recommending in terms of uh just getting
down to brass tacks and saying okay like
how do we get this engine working
uh for for more people
[Music]
i think we have a similar
issue
internationally yeah yeah and talk about
the external disorder cycle you know if
you haven't studied
like
1930s leading to the war or periods like
that then
you don't understand
how wars happen and you don't understand
how this is playing out in the way that
it's played out many many times for
example
sanctions that that economic warfare
you know and the acceleration in those
things
have always preceded military warfare
because
um like in japan um the united states
froze uh japanese assets
and um and
uh did embargo to uh curtail their oil
imports and
and then that put them in a position
where they reacted when we had pearl
harbor and then we have the wars you
need to understand it not just because
it's history
but you need to understand it
because how you navigate it
you may not be able to change the world
okay we think what should we do to
change the world to solve the problems
well
we may not be able to
but you still
should understand
what does it mean for you personally how
do you personally navigate it
and and what are the classic patterns
you know for example you could have
foreign exchange controls we talked
about the depreciation of the value of
money what what how does one save
in that kind of environment how do we
know it's coming what do i mean
i think that we're at a juncture now um
that the sides are
developing both sides
the allied like the allied and the
access power kind of thing i think both
sides
would benefit
from
putting the number one priority
is that they don't have
um a terrible war
yeah i mean that seems self-evident to
all of us though in your book
you talk very very uh convincingly about
the forces that tend to lead great
powers to war
and that right now uh the u.s is in
relative decline china is in relative
assent
uh and that if there is going to be a
conflict uh it it may break out uh
between the us and china with taiwan as
a potential flashpoint and china and
russia having being more on the same
side
and then other countries we're seeing it
now develop in in in that particular way
however
all countries
and all leaders
should know that um how terrible worlds
are the interesting thing about history
you you know we never experienced what
our parents experienced or what the
prior generation experienced so we
that's why we never learned
um and all people
who were the most ardent about let's go
in there and fight and win
um everybody regretted wars because of
how terrible they were
and that's also one of the reasons that
um bad war period led to relatively
extensive periods of peace because
nobody wanted to go they learned that
lesson
that as the number one priority in other
words you can have competitions
between systems
but you you just can't cross the line
you have to know that line and you in
you and you have the rules of the game
assuring that you don't cross that line
beyond that the next thing is how do you
become strong
just be don't don't become a declining
power because a strong power what does
that mean
educate your children well be civil with
each other
earn more than you spend you know these
basic things what is it
what does strong mean and so that's one
of the reasons that bad economic
conditions not only cause internal
conflict they cause a nationalism they
cause
a
populism that also causes international
wars when there's comparability and
powers and so to be um equally mindful
of the need to be to get through that
and by putting that as the number one
now of course i'm talking to
policymakers but then also individuals
who may not be able to shape it
to understand
these things that's how and how to
navigate it
that's that's very very important to me
how do you save
how do you where do you live
who do you associate with those kinds of
things are individual decisions that
could be made to make um even whatever
might happen
better
you you talk about america needing a
strong peacemaker to avoid some kind of
internal civil war it you know it seems
like the same could be true about trying
to navigate this great power rivalry
um you describe between the us and china
in particular and in your book you talk
about how you travel to china starting
in the 80s since before this economic
boom occurred so you kind of saw this
transformation
as it was happening uh one of your sons
the award-winning social entrepreneur
matt dalio actually spent some of his
childhood in schooling
uh in
china so you've had much more direct
exposure to
chinese culture and leadership than
probably just about anyone in the
country i i'd imagine and your book does
talk about how they have a different
approach they tend to be more
uh long-term and even multi-generational
yeah and it's just not
it's not understood and
i wish that we could just
talk about it honestly and uh and
understand it the the big difference is
top-down versus bottom-up and there of
course many many many issues but let's
let's be clear
first you have to be impressed
by the uh what's what's been
accomplished there um and consider them
a force
and by the way through
um
dangchaoping's policies which is a a lot
of capitalism injected into the system
since i started going there um per
capita income income has increased by 26
times the life expectancies increased by
10 years
and the poverty rate of measured by
hunger has gone from 88 percent to less
than one percent they've accomplished a
lot yeah that was staggering i saw less
than one percent i was like wow you know
i mean and it's higher in the us and so
they have their approach and they're
having and we have another approach and
approaches are almost like religions
okay so what are you going to do about
it do you want to fight about the
approach
um or do you want to accept the
religions you know what you should do
number one is be strong
okay yours your best approach
to be as strong as you can because if
you're strong and healthy
uh you're going to be in good shape
that's what it comes down to are you
strong and healthy so i think we have to
focus on that and then focus still no
matter what system it is is
let's not do one of those intolerable
wars
you know it's not i agree
and we're at the brink
of not only the military but you're at
the brink of of what could be an um an
economically devastating war
for example um
if
if doing business in china
um became like doing business in russia
in other words it's not the thing to do
it's politically not the thing to do the
economic consequences because of how our
economies are linked
would be mammoth uh 22 percent of our
manufactured goods imports come from
china
i mean made in china just imagine you
don't get that i mean so that carries
from
um you know something as simple as the
nike shoes that people wear to uh the
apple products
or um the intel chips
and and all of that and
you know so one of the problems that
people don't like about the uh war with
russia is the economic consequences of
that war but those are minor by
comparison this is an issue where um you
know like you have to think hard
about how you don't want the absolutely
catastrophic results how you want to
avoid those things amen ray i mean there
was so much to learn in your book the
changing world order why nations succeed
and and fail really i think one of the
major themes your book is that we have
these massive forces that drive us in
particular directions and some of these
directions are very very nasty they can
lead to world war they can lead to civil
war and revolution and so the question
is how do you actually counteract those
forces how do you start countervailing
forces how do you get enough people and
resource together to say look we do not
need to follow the pattern that so many
other countries have fallen
or great powers have fallen in terms of
combat and i think that's the most
fundamental challenge of our time but
it's certainly going to take real
leadership it's going to take real
strength and fortitude and courage and a
vision uh and you're providing a lot of
those things to a lot of people well i
think me for me and like for you
i would feel terrible about myself
if i if we didn't talk about these
things people can make the choices for
themselves that's one of the great
things about you know our country and
our system but we should talk about
these things a lot of people
um right now are afraid to talk about
the difficult things and so i appreciate
being on your show and i appreciate you
talking about them thank you thank you
for your time
[Music]
you